COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some texture compression
gurus solve their bucket
creation problems.
Will we zip up
their performance?
Stay tuned to find out.
Encode A La Mode came to
us with a small problem.
Their cloud-based texture
compression service
was handling 23,000
encodings a day.
And some of their
clients were starting
to notice that the time it
took to export their data
was starting to get
significantly longer.
Their system works
something like this.
For each build,
their script would
create a new bucket
in cloud storage,
upload all the textures
from the client,
and then kick off work
to a load balancer, where
a bunch of Compute
Engine instances
would start converting textures.
Their setup required that
for each batch of textures
to be uploaded, a
unique bucket was
created so that they
can more easily track
the progress of encoding state.
Although their setup
was pretty sound,
they couldn't ignore
their customers' notes
about performance, so it was
time to dig in and figure out
the problem.
Our first step was to check
the load balancing and scaling
operation.
If everything was set
up right, new instances
should be spun up properly.
So to check that out, we
looked at the CPU utilization
for the instance group.
The values were low,
about in the 12% range,
and there was only about three
to four instances running.
So the problem was
not that the instance
were getting overloaded.
Now, with CPU rates
that low, the next thing
we had to check to make
sure was that machines
weren't getting stalled,
crashing, or hitting
a weird error condition.
But according to the logs,
they were receiving data
right on time.
And, in fact, most of the
instances in the group
were sitting around
just waiting for work.
With the instance group
removed as a potential source
of the problem, we set
our gaze to the GCS bucket
and how the team was using it.
And, lo and behold, ran
right into the issue.
It turns out that there
is a per-project rate
limit to bucket creation and
deletion of approximately
one operation every two seconds,
according to the documentation.
For them, this meant
that if 30 artists
across multiple
companies all tried
to export at the same
time, then random folks
would start getting
exception 429 to be thrown,
signaling that the rate was
exceeded for bucket creation.
Where this turned into
a performance problem
was that the Python API
their tool was using
had to implement an exponential
back-off and retry, which
is nice and common practice.
But since the queue
was getting backed up,
folks were ending up
waiting a longer time
for a simple export.
Turns out they didn't need that
much dynamic bucket creation.
Instead they created one
bucket for each artist
as they registered
with the system.
This removed the entire
bucket creation bottleneck,
making things a lot
faster and made it easier
to handle tracking down what
assets were causing problems
in the case of an error.
To learn more about the perf
details of these buckets,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]